our 8 news now investigators obtaining
shocking images of a violent home
invasion in an exclusive Valley
neighborhood police say a group broke
into this home binding a couple with
duct tape and forcing one person's head
underwater before trying to sell the
stolen goods from that home online we
thank you for joining us on 8 news now
at six I'm Brian Loftus I'm Christian
Joyce this group is Accused in multiple
burglaries and home invasions across our
area from Henderson to Summerlin a news
now investigator David Charles now with
the details in all eight people face
charges in this series of home invasions
some of them right now in custody here
at the Clark County Jail these involved
the shooting at one person's home in
Henderson and that other incident in
Summerlin where our couple was allegedly
bound and tortured drone video from
above the gated queensridge neighborhood
in the West Valley shows several homes
of budding open land it's the former
Badlands Golf Course detectives suspect
the group targeted homes like these off
of public paths in open space photos
show the door prosecutors allege four
men entered to break into this fifteen
thousand square foot mansion once inside
the group is accused of binding a man
and woman with duct tape beating them in
quote forcing them around their home
opening safes to steal money jewelry and
purses this crime scene photo showing
one ransacked room at one point the
group forcing one victim's head under
water in her own bathtub the woman
telling a grand jury she couldn't
breathe as someone held her head
underwater at least three times police
say the group ended up getting away with
handbags luxury items that soon popped
up online detectives say 28 year old
Raven Queen tried to sell the stolen
items on Facebook ultimately police
believe the group is involved in as many
as a dozen home invasions across the
valley photos showing a broken door from
a burglary in Henderson in a separate
case police believe the group targeted a
YouTube personality two teenage burglars
shooting that man as he woke up startled
in the middle of the night to the sound
of them in his bedroom police believe
the group came to the Las Vegas area
from California these surveillance
images showing them in a hotel they also
stayed at an Airbnb before their arrest
right now three of those defendants are
in custody here at the jail behind me
others in custody and other
jurisdictions including in California
the alleged ringleader Raven Queen held
right now on 750 thousand dollars bail
outside the Regional Justice Center in
downtown Las Vegas I'm David Charles 8
News Now David thank you the Henderson
shooting victim recovered from his
injuries as for the Queen's Ridge home
invasion a 77 year old man is recovering
now from a brain injury